day 2 of the 2017 grand chest tour here  in Paris the best players on the planet  tried to calm their nerves after a wild  first day where mistakes seem to come at  a rapid pace the newest member of the  2,800 club shaq rearmament dr o played  fantastic chess  winning a lot of three games in crushing  styles the end the day in sole  possession of third place world champion  Magnus Carlsen also won two games in  dominating style but after hold off a  main rival is our dr. Mora to keep us  slim lead over the resource American  going into the third day of competition  it's time to decide who will earn  bragging rights as the king of Rapids  they scream like our son right now